-Here's how the game works.
Salma and I will take turns
facing our backs to the curtain.
Behind the curtain will be
something
neither of us have seen before.
It could be
people, objects, anything.
We have 45 seconds to try
to get the other person
to guess what's behind them.
You can say anything you want.
You can use gestures.
You just can't say any of
the words on the card.
Salma, you'll be guessing first,
so let's get into position.
-Oh, God. This is...
You mean, like, I'm going to --
-Yeah, you'll face me now, yeah.
-Okay, okay.
-That cost us $3 million to
make, by the way.
-Okay.
-Alright, here we...
Alright. Alright.
Salma, let's see
what's behind you.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Okay --
-You're wasting time!
-Sorry, sorry, sorry!
This is a...
Daniel Radcliffe played him
in like six movies.
The books.
J.K. Rowling.
-"Harry Potter."
-Yes, okay.
And then Mike Myers played him.
He's a spy from the '60s.
Very funny movie.
-Oh, the one with the --
-Yes.
-Mike Myers! No.
-No, not his is -- Yeah.
-Oh, my God. I know, I know.
And say what's in it.
I know the movie,
but what's his name?
-Texas. It's a place in Texas.
-Oh, gosh.
-His last name is --
-Austin Powers!
-Yes, yes, yes! Alright.
They're not flying.
They're not flying --
They're on a kite.
They're holding on to
a kite kind of.
But what's that called?
-They're holding on to a kite?
What's that called?
-Yeah, like if you're -- If
you're flying but with a kite.
-Suspended. Cruising.
Hang gliding.
-Yes! That's it!
We got it! We got it!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God. I got it!
-Yeah, baby!
-I got it!
-Alright. Here we go.
Alright. That's Harry Potter.
-Oh, that's brilliant.
-Get his teeth.
Get his teeth out there.
Did you get his teeth?
-Don't put it in your mouth.
-Here you go, buddy.
No problem.
His teeth fell out. Alright.
Alright, now it's my turn
to guess.
Alright, let's rotate the stage.
Here we go.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I take this, right?
-Alright, grab the blue card,
and when the curtains open,
the time starts
when you start talking.
Let's see what is behind me.
♪♪
-Oh, my God! Okay.
So, the bad guy in black
from "Star Wars."
-Darth Vader.
[ Ding ]
And then -- You know when
you have a kid,
and you bring somebody
to do this thing.
And then you blow...
You know?
And it's, like, plastic.
Bad for the environment.
And it's --
You can go on a trip.
You can get on it and go on a
trip, and it's a --
-Yeah, I know. Yeah, yeah.
-And it gets bigger.
-It gets bigger and bigger.
Yeah, yeah.
-How do you call that?
Kids' parties, kids' parties.
-Balloon.
-Yes!
-Alright, hot-air balloon.
-And then it's not a person.
It's, like, a dog or a --
-A cat. A pet. An animal.
-Yes. So?
-An animal balloon.
Balloon animal!
-Yes.
-Darth Vader balloon animal.
-And then it's in
the tower that is crooked.
-Oh, yeah!
Leaning Tower of Pisa!
-Yes!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-It's stressful, right?
-My God.
What else would you blow on?
What else would you blow on
that it took you so long
to figure it out?
-Trust me --
it doesn't take me that long.
Alright, let's --
Your turn to guess.
Let's rotate the stage.
Okay. Here we go.
Let's see what's behind Salma.
Let's see what's behind you.
Open the curtain, please.
[ Clears throat ]
-This is so stressful.
♪♪
-Okay. Alright, alright.
Okay, I kind of guessed at this.
Okay. It's a dance.
It's a famous dance
from the '90s.
-Salsa.
-No.
-Flamenco.
-[ Vocalizes "Macarena" ]
-The Macarena.
-Yes. Okay. That's good.
-Okay.
-And it is a famous TV show
in America,
one of the biggest shows
in the '90s.
Jennifer Aniston.
-"Friends."
-Yes!
[ Ding ]
They're in front of a --
A gas-station store that sells,
like, you know, hot dogs --
-7-Eleven.
-Yes! Yes!
The cast of "Friends."
♪♪
-Yes.
-The cast of "Friends"
doing the Macarena
in front of a 7-Eleven.
-Wonderful.
-Oh, my gosh.
I think Austin Powers' teeth
is over there, as well.
Alright, it is the final round.
Let's rotate the stage, please.
Here we go.
-Oh, God.
-Come on. No, you were great.
You're good at this.
This is great.
Now, when we're ready.
[ Clears throat ]
Let's see what's behind me.
-Here we go.
-Alright, here we go.
-Okay. Oh! Okay.
It's an animal with a big tail.
They tread in the water.
-Crocodile.
-No, they don't have a big tail,
the crocodile.
-Alligator?
-You eat it. You eat it.
You shouldn't, but we eat it.
-Shrimp.
-The bigger one
with the bigger tail.
-Lobster.
-Yes.
And then it's doing this.
-Oh, my gosh.
-It's doing this.
-Slapping.
-On the butt.
-Slapping on the butt.
-No, you would say that -- How
would you call this, honey?
How do you...
-My wife is watching!
My wife is watching!
-How do you call that?
-Bad girl? Bad...
-No. The act of --
Starts with a --
-Spanking.
-Thank you!
-Alright.
-And then one of those
brilliant minds of all time.
-Albert Einstein.
-Thank you!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
What it takes you
to get to the --
-That is amazing.
You were unbelievable.
Salma Hayek Pinault!
I love you.